über die beschlossene Wahlrechtsreform
sprechen wir jetzt mit der
parteienrechtlerin Sophie Schönberger
von der Universität Düsseldorf sie wurde
als Sachverständige von der SPD
nominiert hallo Frau Professor Sophie
Schönberger schön dass Sie bei uns sind
ja jetzt nach dem heutigen Tag wollen
die Linkspartei die Union und der
Freistaat Bayern gemeinsam gegen diese
Wahlrechtsreform Vorgehen was glauben
denn sie würde diese Wahlrechtsreform in
Karlsruhe gekippt werden können halten
Sie die so wie sie gerade ist für
verfassungsrechtlich angreifbar ich
halte die für absolut verfassungskonform
und bin da sehr zuversichtlich und sehr
gelassen dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht dieses neue
Wahlrecht auch so bestätigen wird
ein Punkt über den ja gerade viel
gesprochen wird ist diese
grundmandatsklausel noch mal zu
Erklärung die hat bisher geregelt das
Parteien auch ohne diese fünf Prozent
Hürde zu erklimmen es schaffen können
als in Fraktion stärker in den Bundestag
einzuziehen nämlich wenn man drei
Direktmandate gewinnt und die soll jetzt
entfallen ist es denn aus ihrer Sicht
okay die abzuschaffen und wenn ja warum
es ist eine politische Entscheidung man
muss es so sehen diese Grundmann das
Klausel ist eine
rechtfertigungsbedürftige Ausnahmen es
ist eine Sonderregel eine Ausnahme von
der 5% Hürde deswegen
ehrlich gesagt die Grundmann ganz
Klausel selber ist eine Beeinträchtigung
der wahlrechtsgleichheit die man
rechtfertigen muss man kann das
rechtfertigen es ist also zulässig sie
einzuführen aber es gibt überhaupt gar
keine Gründe zu behaupten dass es
verfassungsrechtlich zwingend geboten
wäre sie beizubehalten erst recht nicht
wenn man das Wahlsystem der Sache nach
auf dem reines Verhältniswahlsystem
umstellt
vielleicht noch mal für euch als Kontext
die letzte Partei die von dieser
grundmandatsklausel profitiert hat war
bei der Bundestagswahl 2021 die Linke
die nicht 5% erreicht hat bei den
Zweitstimmen aber in drei mindestens
drei Wahlkreisen gewonnen hat und somit
jetzt als Fraktion im Bundestag sitzt
und es gibt ja dazu aber auch andere
Stimmen jetzt sagen andere
rechtswissenschaftlerinnen z.B dass
diese
grundmandatsklausel unabdingbar ist für
die Chancengleichheit im politischen
Wettbewerb was sagen sie dazu
es scheint mir kein
verfassungsrechtliches sondern ein
politisches Argument zu sein dass man
sagt das ist gerechte es ist
chancengleicher wenn man sie drin hat
darüber kann man politisch streiten wie
gesagt ich sehe das nicht weil es sich
hier um eine Sonderregelung eine
Ausnahme
elt bestimmte Parteien profitieren
andere nicht
aber ein verfassungsrechtliches Argument
lässt sich der meiner Meinung nach nicht
aus dem Zimmer
weil wir ja hier mit vielen
verschiedenen Begriffen um uns werfen
und das vielleicht finde ich alle ganz
klar es können Sie uns noch mal
zusammenfassen was sieht denn das
Wahlrecht da ganz konkret vor wird davon
einer grundmandatsklausel gesprochen
meinen Sie jetzt das Geld eine Wahlrecht
oder das Verfassungsrecht das
Verfassungsrecht sorry das
Verfassungsrecht sagt gar nichts außer
dass die Wahlen allgemein gleich frei
und unmittelbar sein müssen und da ist
von der Grundmann als Klausel überhaupt
keine Rede umgekehrt zwar dass die
Verfassung sagt die Wahl müssen gleich
sein das heißt unter gleichen Bedingung
stattfinden das heißt erstmal auch
grundsätzlich das für alle die fünf
Prozent würde geht wenn man davon
abweicht und sagt für die Parteien die
in Wahlkreisen punktuell besonders
erfolgreich sind in der Breite aber
nicht erfolgreich machen wir davon eine
Ausnahme dann ist das ja eine
Ungleichbehandlung die muss ich
verfassungsrechtlich rechtfertigen aber
umgekehrt ein Argument raus zu stricken
dass ich sage weil ich eine gleiche Wahl
habe muss ich zwingen eine Ungleichheit
mit in das Wahlsystem einbauen das ist
nicht erklärlich
jetzt ist ja eine Partei die ein großes
Problem mit dieser Wahlrechtsreform hat
die CSU die zwar Direktmandate gewinnt
aber als stark regionale Partei also als
eine Partei die nur in Bayern antritt da
ist einfach nicht klar gesagt dass die
bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl auch
wieder über diese fünf Prozent Hürde
kommt jetzt sieht diese neue
Wahlrechtsreform aber auch vor dass zum
Beispiel unabhängige Kandidaten
einfacher ohne diese 5% Hürde in den
Bundestag kommen können das hört sich ja
erstmal ungerecht an oder
also was ihre Form tatsächlich vorsieht
ist ähm das unabhängige Partei
unabhängige Kandidaten anders behandelt
werden als Partei gebundene Kandidaten
darüber kann man streiten ob das so in
Ordnung ist ich halte auch das für zu
Rechtfertigung weil eben unabhängige
Kandidaten natürlich andere Rolle haben
oder ohnehin deutlich schlechtere
Chancen haben und in der Praxis ohnehin
wir im Grunde noch nie eine vollkommen
unabhängigen Kandidaten
unterschiedlich theoretische Möglichkeit
umgekehrt ist es so den Abschaffung der
grundmannsklausel sieht insofern gleiche
Bedingungen für alle Partei Kandidaten
vor als das eben alle
Prozenthürde gebunden sind ohne Ausnahme
jetzt ist es ja künftig so dass nicht
mehr jeder Sieger oder jede Siegerin
eines Wahlkreises automatisch in den
Bundestag einziehen würde
da geht es dann vor allem auch über die
Priorität auf der Landesliste jetzt
sagen einige die von dieser Reform dann
betroffen wären Mensch mein Wahlkreis
ist aber verhältnismäßig total groß die
Anzahl der Wähler und WählerInnen in
meinem Wahlkreis ist größer als bei
anderen wie fair ist das denn dann muss
man auch über die Wahlkreis Größe
sprechen
die Toleranzen in den Wahlkreisen werden
ja auch abgesenkt durch die
Wahlrechtsreform aber es geht ja wenn
ich es richtig im Kopf habe nicht um die
aktuelle
Stimmenzahl sondern um die Prozent
zahlen insofern greift das Argument
eigentlich nicht durch
ja wir haben eben schon darüber
gesprochen dass auch die CSU ein Problem
mit dieser neuen Regelung hat wie ist
das denn würde es zukünftig auch die
Möglichkeit so ich habe
parteiübergreifen verbundene Listen
geben also könnte die CSU theoretisch so
eine Listenverbindung mit der CDU
eingehen oder irgendwie eine Partei
werden
also eine Partei zu werden das steht der
Union natürlich immer frei es steht
jetzt CSU auch frei bundesweit
anzutreten das sind alles
Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten die da bestehen
die Listenverbindungen sind wenn ich es
richtig sehe auch im neuen Entwurf nicht
vorgesehen das könnte man ins Gesetz
reinschreiben hat man aber nicht wie
gesagt jede Partei hat die Möglichkeit
sich zu einer Gesamtheit
zusammenzuschließen oder im gesamten
Bundesgebiet mit kein eigenen Kandidaten
anzutreten
ja wir werden mal gucken wie es da in
der Richtung weitergeht vielen Dank Frau
Schönberger dass sie meine Fragen so
beantwortet haben danke schön